I always love the postal system dude you
know I'm saying sometimes the postal
system you know that could be you know
like when I was young you had to use
that thing and I'm saying you wanted to
tell somebody you cared bro you better
[ __ ] in you had to write it down put it
it take one piece of paper folds up put
it into another piece of paper get a
special secret little thing stamp lick
it get a lick the back of it do it
already this sounds like something you
know this sounds like a way you're gonna
end up high or something then you had to
put the thing you licked onto the other
thing right then you had to write
exactly where was supposed to go on the
front then you had to go put it in a box
out in your front yard
if this doesn't sound like a [ __ ]
script for Narnia
I can't even tell you what does then a
man you didn't even know who gets bit by
dogs and animals all the time had to
come and pick it up and take it away and
every now and then you would hear that
one of those men went insane and shot up
his work facility and that was mail so I
respect so much Nelson you out there you
know you out there still riding the
rails
you know because mail is it's really man
it's the Greyhound bus of communication
dude anything can happen
do when I lived in Tucson Arizona I used
to live in Tucson Arizona I used to I
was a busboy out there for a long time
at a place called City Grill one of my
favorite I mean I loved that job so much
man I loved being a busboy you know dude
you were just [ __ ] slinging around and
people are doing dope and you know the
guy who worked the oven would always be
falling asleep and you wake that dude up
before he [ __ ] burned himself but
they had a postman boss dude this dude
he was on something you know he was gang
ganging up in his wrist or something or
just hiding you know grams of cocaine up
in the up in his nose and he would come
by like three nights a week dude
midnight 11 p.m.
throw all the [ __ ] mail into the
front yard bruh just BAM dude this dude
was just like just making it rain bills
and COO
ponds and and just different ship via
the mail this day would just [ __ ] it
bruh get your [ __ ] and cruise mail truck
unmarked he would spray-paint another
[ __ ] on the side of it dude straight up
just straight up a straight of real just
human vulture man so I know you guys are
living wild out there Nelson I
appreciate you riding the rails brother
dark I mean that's the dark arts that's
the dark arts of delivery communication
right there when you're out there still
you know you're working that mail and
you're fending off animals basically
you're somebody has to fight animals so
you can get like perfume samples and
coupons and grand parental a lot of
grandparents still use that mail system
and and that means so much that when you
get that letter from one even when your
loved ones you know like a lot of people
to Midwest so you know a Midwestern
grandmother she'll [ __ ] write you for
no reason
she'll write you man and she'll just and
that that letter feel so warm and just
toasty and breasty and you read that
thing and it smells like cookies and
feelings and man you do that for people
you delivering those hitters nelson so
thank you for calling and thanks for
listening to this past week and i'd love
to know who's out there who's out there
and who's ears are am i helping baby sit
for a little bit of time on on a monday
halfway to Christmas dude and look at
all these gifts we gettin Nelson out
there one of those freelance elves baby
Goering yeah good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one